hello everybody my name is Markiplier
welcome back to shadow of Rose I know
it's been a while I've been working on
my mom's documentary but that is now
done the TV show I was editing is now
done well done ish on my part which
means that I can finally get back to
this game and I just remembered where I
was but I should be done with that
if I remember correctly I should be done
with that that
okay that's just the goop that should
all be done I don't need to worry about
the mannequins anymore because the
mannequins are not my problem I have the
fuse
everything should be fine and I should
be able to get out of here just fine
I hope this thing
no boy
you're after the crystal aren't you
do you know where it is
I've got it from friends just for you
entertainment and maybe I'll tell
you know I believe this is what they
call moving the goal post
um because I met your criteria already
and then suddenly you won me
further hmm well this isn't that oh
they're big I'm small why am I dying
oh good
Ness
[Music]
let's play hide and seek can you make it
all the way without getting caught oh no
oh no I thought I would be the one that
would be seeking oh man the last time I
played it was on Halloween God is but
I'm sorry about that but
you know I just had work that needed to
be done
that's the way it goes sometimes
and that's what I do because I'm a good
son and I do what I need to do for my
mom well I'm not this way then I guess
all right cool man this perspective is
funky how do I crouch again ah of course
the Crouch button
[ __ ] yeah what
I'm sorry wait a minute hold on what's
with the spider protrusions what if
what's with the Marvel's Iron Spider-Man
what is that supposed to be
[Music]
um
[Music]
I see I see okay
ever let them see me I would know God
where do I go no
no well this is easy well this ain't
nothing you should keep heading this way
I guess I should
Okay so
oh
boy
can I turn off my flashlight or does it
not even matter probably not probably
doesn't even matter okay hey bud
okay what are you doing
tell me your secrets you came back you
drifted back this way which tells me
that you may not
is that the same one as before or is
that a different one I think that's a
yeah that's a different one okay so
there's two down here
one drifts back and forth that way there
seems to be some kind of Alcove over
there so I bet if I follow this one
this way
but when it goes there duck in here
right perfect I am the best then it'll
go back that way okay
well who knows and who cares shut up so
I should be able to go back up that way
but I think
yeah it comes down there so that would
have been death
I do see an Alcove underneath this desk
here which is going to be good for me
[Laughter]
all right wait where did that other one
go wait am I crazy
am I crazy oh no I'm not crazy it's
right there oh my God okay so going
under the desk would be a very bad thing
because it seems like it's it is it
looking right under that desk that would
have been a that would have been an
incredibly dumb move right Elena am I
crazy am I not crazy I think I'm crazy
uh but it's up there now how did we
oh I'm so confused I'm just going
for oh god oh I'm dead oh oh God
okay I'm good I'm good what do I do oh
there's the thing how do I oh man how do
I do that again
oh
I forget the button
for doing that oh god oh no okay hold on
what is it what is it what is it
how have I forgotten the button for this
uh oh come on why won't you scroll
scroll
uh really really really really really
really really really really onslaught
use powers space is that it I don't know
what that is I don't know what Onslaught
is whatever
no
okay so I can't use it I probably just
gotta get closer
probably what it is maybe definitely 100
don't go don't get up
okay I'm just gonna go for it where am I
going I have no idea oh I see I know I
know oh God oh God
okay oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah what is the button
what is the button what is the button
what is what is the button oh what's the
button oh what is the button what what
is the button what what is the button
wait am I crazy what's the what's the
button why don't I remember them I'm
pushing all of the buttons hi it's me
again I haven't had to do this in a
while because I haven't had an
opportunity to be stupid in a while
the answer is really simple but then
again so am I
I'm really simple
you just need to stand up
yeah
I cut out about 10 minutes of me
floundering do I have to be standing for
this
damage
g-space oh my God
you had to be
oh my God you can't use it when you're
crouching
oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
I don't like that
oh I don't like that oh I hate that oh I
hate that oh my God I hate that oh my
God I hate that I hate that in every way
shape and form
oh my God
are you kidding me
oh oh
man
oh what's going on there okay whatever
it's fine
I'm an idiot
but that wasn't really clear
I don't know I don't know why I was just
afraid to stand up I don't know why I
don't know why that was that
yeah yeah get her yeah you got her me
you got me yeah you got me oh yeah
oh yeah good job everybody good job
good job
uh-huh there's gotta be something I can
do
uh-huh
[Music]
perfect
the perfect distraction
yeah I don't know why the ones over
there didn't hear that but
too easy just like everything in this
game too easy all right um
I am
bothered already I'm I'm quite
I'm quite bothered can I sneak by here
is this a man good job looking at those
boxes
uh really really uh really on the
lookout
man nothing flips by you guys I keep up
the good work
angry dub
I can't I probably can't because let's
have to get past them
um
there seems to be a little Gap here
where they're not looking but that one
nope can't reach that okay interesting
I don't know if it's not
probably not
[Music]
hmm maybe here but man that is a
[Music]
okay so there's got to be a way to get
down here that they're not looking but
it sure looks like they're looking like
that really looks like they're looking
but uh oh it drops
okay well that's good man this is all
extremely convenient I was making it a
lot harder than I needed to make it
so
it seems like maybe
if you go back
oh there's two of you
[Music]
nope never
enough
all right
well if I have no new if I had to noon
if I'd have known it wasn't going to
take any strategy okay
I think I gotta go under the desk I'm
not 100 sure but I think I gotta go wow
that was quick what was that about holy
crap
okay that was weird
was that just me or was I not looking or
was that really really quick
I don't hear the other one comes it's
coming quick
no no it's not
no it wasn't quick
I just wasn't paying attention Okay I
gotta go in
Hondo
why am I here oh man oh
all right
yeah get me
I'm just gonna see if there's any
petroleum still probably not
probably not oh
just checking
just checking
good job keep it up I'm almost dead I'm
real tough though
fine
you'll get me eventually
I climb back up no okay so what other
way was I supposed to go
please tell me how I'm being dumb again
because I am I know it
I get out here before some horrible
happens oh good
okay good
that's great oh we're here why didn't
well what is happening
what's that
[Music]
way that's what I was saying yeah no way
um okay well this is horrifying and
terrible
oh no
oh no oh do I go I'm gonna go oh my God
I'm gonna
oh my God oh my God I'm going for it oh
my God oh my God oh my God
oh okay I'm sure they're giving me this
for a reason I'm sure that I need to
freeze something for a reason
I'll know it when I see it oh God
freeze okay that's definitely gotta be
it because otherwise I would have been
caught
I would have been caught immediately I
know it 100 I know it oh my God
hopefully nothing's coming up behind me
okay
where are you going where are you going
good good good excellent nice one oh God
if I run into their backs I don't know
if it's gonna go too good for me
oh what what do you mean about me
I did just say if I run into their backs
it's not gonna go good for me oh I'm
alive
Oh I thought that would have been the
end for me
I think wow
really I'm really well okay well you're
an idiot man my footing has never been
less stable
oh God okay what if I you well never
mind oh my God can I please I am so
stumbly
I got which way are you gonna go oh no
no
no
no no no oh no oh God no no no no
oh oh frick oh freaking oh my freak
where are you going
I don't know where you're going I don't
know why you're going that way but I
don't know where you're going
oh I don't know why I need to go to the
bedroom that that's something that I
missed out on why do I need to go to the
bedroom
I don't fully understand
yay cutscene oh bamboo cutscene
hey hey
Shut up you know it's true
what is fun with her
[Music]
oh she might care
shut up shut up shut up
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that'll hold it
[Music]
I'm guessing I go yes I go I go now oh
hi hello all right uh whoa hey oh
that's me
oh you want to be my friend okay
yeah I'm guessing this is why I don't
have any friends because I keep turning
them away wow
okay
all right
um
oops
perfect just as planned everything going
according to my grand scheme
why are they talking about my dad I
never even met him
no way I don't know
I don't know the first thing about him
I wish I did
all I know is he died protecting me
[Music]
sometimes
try to imagine what my life would have
been like if he hadn't died
taught me to ride a bike helps me with
my homework
story every night
but you've been there for me proud of me
sometimes
when I feel lost or afraid
try to imagine what he might have said
to me
[Music]
foreign
where am I how did I get here what
happened
it feels
familiar
like
I've been here before
look at all the decorations
some kind of party hmm decorate the
living room done get wine put in the
dining room yep Rose's other person in
the study hidden hmm so I I mean my
thought
don't forget to look upstairs well I'm
not done yet hold on there pops hold on
there
Papa
yes you wait I'm I mean that was my
original Theory and I'm pretty sure
that's not that much of a secret I'm
pretty sure everybody probably thought
that that was uh Mr Winters
lucky to have you both in my life
that's just my parents house from when I
was a baby hmm
I had other things also have my dad's
memories
you would better so little
hard to believe one day she'll be old
enough to share a bottle of wine with
her old man
found out was a Wine Drinker
freaking Wine Drinker earlier every time
I play this I wonder if she'll be a
musician
I wonder if Dad played any instruments
I don't even know what Miss D and the
Paul boys is Misty
lady
couldn't be
she just cannot get enough of this stuff
I bet Dad would feed me as soon as I
started crying
probably I think that's how babies work
but don't ask me I'm no expert
[Music]
pantry
oh
whoa
Rose is such a picky eater all she ever
wants is fruit puree I guess I've always
loved fruit
just like mushrooms
I think is that the connection that I'm
supposed to make there
dude
fungal people like fruit is that the
connection I have no idea
hello hmm what Memories in here
no memories zero shower memories
fine
what about over here I don't remember
which one is Rosa's room so Ethan don't
forget Rose's half birthday is on the
second I'm gonna make you I'm gonna make
an amazing cake so you better eat it in
fact I'm gonna make a cake for every
special occasion we have I want you to
take lots of pictures for our family
ages
oh yeah I forgot that her mom's still
alive yeah I wonder why
I guess they've grown distant
something like that
hello oh wait no not yet
not yet unless that's the thing that I'm
supposed to see I never know which one
comes first
always been special for our family
I think I've heard this before
it's pretty
this is no my bedroom wait
no no no okay it must have been that one
first I never know these things because
I always feel like I'm gonna get
something that's gonna end the whole
scene and then I'm gonna move on without
getting anything but it must be this
she's probably a little too young for
this but it was too cute a big nice
block I wonder how we've played with
this
a big dice block that was it I thought
it was going to be magical
I mean it's got magical ooze shooting up
from around its sides but I don't think
that means it's magical
hmm
crib there hold on hold on
interesting maybe the crib first it's
got the wall I never know
she's growing so fast
getting bigger every day
crib is so little that's again how
babies work
she's already growing out of these
onesies
I can't believe I was ever this tiny
again
that's kind of just how babies work
anything else besides that laptop that
laptop feels final
uh wait oh
interesting February 2nd is Rose's half
birthday half a year in the blink of an
eye I wanted to capture this moment
these feelings so I wrote something
special I may have gotten a bit sappy
though I'd feel embarrassed if anyone
stumbles across it so it's safe on the
sideboard for now
Keys behind my favorite photo
I see my favorite photo I wonder if
she'll look like me when she grows up
I don't know we never saw your face
happy I don't know if that's Happy
nobody would call happy I don't know
what was that
is that something special this is
someone
writing something okay whatever
special embarrassing letter for me
happy half birthday Rose
and a gift to you is a promise
I'll always be there for you no matter
what
I'll be there every birthday to watch
you blow out the candles on your cake
I'll be there to make you breakfast and
walk you to school every day I'll be
there when you have a bad dream and sing
to you until you fall back asleep
I'll hug you tight when you're troubled
or worried and tell you that
everything's gonna be all right
You Are My Precious Rose
never forget that Dad
no one loves you
how embarrassing am I right everybody
is that Resident Evil 7 villain is that
villain from Seven I have no idea I
think so probably oh no I'm gooped
guess what what chicken butt
looking for
isn't here
don't have the purifying Crystal
of course not
for that
you'll have to go deeper
much deeper
Rose
she can't trust anyone why are you doing
this
no one loves you
and want your text
no one welcome
[Laughter]
no one will care enough games
okay all right whatever you say I'm
guessing I was supposed to just go
forward
hi what you first
I don't know what that means I mean I
know what that means in Resident Evil 7
terms
who what are you talking about
what do you think
well I don't know about that one of us
is alive
rain in a jar
fungal brain in a jar that you know
what's your problem talk about not
having any friends
here oh white sage all right well that's
probably important
uh I was going to do the
I was gonna do the the other thing okay
this is this is a little rude I think
that I think that I I was gonna you know
are they still there or something or was
it what's the deal I don't know
all right I don't know what's going on
I think that was supposed to happen
no no no no no stop
stop okay I should probably go
no no no no okay good
all right well
uh no I'm gonna go with uh no
stop all right and oh there's two
all right Goku now now would be a good
time hey
chance
what if I just punch you in the face
what if I just Wham right in the face
who's day
I don't know I don't know
Michael
I died
all right
well
not safe yet well you said that we were
safe before and I'm like
oh it is Evelyn Evelyn that's wonderful
seven
yeah you said you were we were safe
before and then we very much weren't and
then I got pulled into the demon realm
again
so we still can't get out
um okay why uh I thought it was always
an option to turn back but uh okay
oh that's not good
I don't think that's very good
use your powers on her
I can help once she's weak oh boss
battle
okay
oh wait a minute upgrade these should
help
wait a minute I knew that sound that
sound
that Roar that was from
that Roar that just occurred
I've heard that in SCP Containment
Breach that's weird
also I didn't get a cut scene for that
new upgrade it's just upgrade and done
sure whatever fine
I'm not hurt by that
let's go beat up a little girl don't
panic you've got this
I know I'm fine don't worry about me
I'll be all right
it's dark
stop
how okay wow that I don't feel like I
should use this on the first go of
things
such a good girl ow I don't know if that
oh wow okay that was probably my opening
we were supposed to be a family
there we go
she's not done be careful oh boy
I don't know
look don't ask me I'm just I was just
born
[Music]
here
uh-huh watch my step oh God
oh
boy
you're stupid
it's really it's just a slap fight
you're stupid you're stupid
oh boy oh wait wait wait oh
you know as much as I love this slap
fight I think that um
oh God nope hold on
I don't know about that
I mean you're the one that's just
slapping
you have me
all right
hey come on
keep focusing I'll help
all right
[Applause]
oh
believe it but now
this is all your fault
and I will never let you have what you
want close look out
don't give up find that Crystal
oh
where are we going next
I really like that whole sequence not
not necessarily the boss battle the boss
battles whatever like in these games
kind of like the boss battles of have
never been quite as grandiose as I would
ever hope in some of them some of them
are fantastic but like the ending boss
of Resident Evils 8 was just like
completely underwhelming and that was
like it was okay I mean I'm I'm not come
across critical I'm trying to be like
really nice I like the whole sequence of
being scary it was very spooky and it
was good change Pace really getting into
the horror of things not the scariest
thing I've ever done
I don't like mannequins
that voice
is Michael
my dad
don't give up Rose find that Crystal
it's a logical
like rose
I can keep going we can keep going
remember I'm the voice inside your head
Crystal
I guess I have to finance Crystal
okay but where am I now
but I have to keep going I guess I'm on
my own and I have to keep going but I'll
keep going in the next episode because
at some point here
lady dimitrisku is waiting in the
shadows so thank you everybody so much
for watching once again I am back
officially
um the day that you see this video is
the last day to see my mom's documentary
um after that it'll be gone uh but if
you want it's five dollars off uh and
Link is in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching regular
videos now back
thank you and as always I'll see you in
the next one bye bye